I'm making this for people who want to
get rich. And if that is not you, that
is totally fine. There's no judgment,
you can skip this. But this is for
people who are trying to, call it, money
max for the short period. So, if you if
you want to max, you have to min, and
you have to be willing to do that for a
period of time.
And so, I'm going to give you an
argument that I think is very compelling
for why you should do it sooner. And so,
if you want to get rich, then you should
try and get rich as young as possible,
and I will break down very logical
reasons for why. So, number one, first
and foremost, one of the most underrated
reasons is the math behind getting
wealthy. All right, so money compounds
at three to four times the rate in the
beginning as it does later, meaning
your increase in compounding on the
excess cash you have in the earlier
parts of your um
uh career will outpace the increase in
earning power. And so, for example,
if you have $1 extra when you're 25, it
might be $90 by the time you're 70,
right? Whereas if that same dollar at 35
uh would only be a third as much. And
that same dollar at uh 45 would be a
ninth as much, right? And so, the idea
is uh the dollars that you make, even
though they may be smaller by
proportion, when you get when you allow
compounding to compound, uh actually
results in more money later. Now, my
argument there is not that you must take
100% of your dollars and put it into the
S&P 500, that's never been my argument.
But that the dollars you do choose to
put into investments of any kind at an
earlier part in your in your career do
get disproportionate returns. So, that's
thing one. The second thing
is that your skills will also compound
disproportionately that you acquired at
a younger age, right? Like, there's a
certain amount of repetitions that are
required in order for you to become
good. Bill Gates was able to get those
repetitions early because he started
coding early, and then as a result he
was able to build software first, and
then basically was able to keep this
kind of sustained advantage. Like, I
talked to a guy yesterday uh uh not
yesterday, 2 days ago, Mehdi, who had
$700,000 by the time he was 19, right,
that saved up. That was very
interesting. Now, imagine that that was
a 65-year-old guy. We wouldn't be as
impressed, right? And so, time has very
real impact on the scope or scale of
your accomplishments as it relates to
your reputation. Meaning, when I was
younger and a millionaire early, it
meant a lot more, and so you actually
get more reputational
um
uh gravitas, right? And so, um you can
leverage a smaller win when you are
younger for your reputation because you
are younger, right? And I'll give you a
secret that I, you know, only found out
later, is that you basically have until
you're 30 to be considered young. The
moment I turned 30, I was just a white
dude.
>> [laughter]
>> Before that, I was a young white dude.
Uh then I was just white dude, and then
no one cared after that, right? So, in
other words, youth is a multiplier on
every win that you have, wh- whether
that be press, network, mentors, capital
access. Um I just made an investment uh
this last week. Uh I wrote a $500,000
check to a kid who was 18 years old, uh
and he was doing he had just done $30
million a year in e-commerce business
and wanted to develop a tool
um
to uh to help e-commerce stores. So, I
was like, I knew he had the avatar, I
knew he'd be able to do it, but the fact
that he was 18 and had accomplished that
made me think, "Okay, this guy is really
sharp." Now, he got into my stuff at age
15. So, it took him 3 years to get
there, right? But in other words, um
that multiplier decays around 30, right?
But so, you have this period of time
where going all in yields higher returns
even for the same outcome. Now, number
three.
You leverage early success into bigger
later success. So, his $30 million
business uh obviously everything's
different in terms of what your scale of
success is, right? But
you can you can you can ladder on top of
it. They're stepping stones.
So, for example, me, when I went through
the beginning, it was like I was able to
get in shape really early, and I was
able to leverage that into personal
training and online training clients,
which I was able to leverage into a gym,
and then from gym I got into multiple
gyms, and then from multiple gyms I was
able to start Gym Launch. And so, the
thing is is that every part of my career
has been going back and basically taking
a stepping stone on what I learned from
the enterprise I did before. And then,
obviously the sale of Gym Launch got
basically gave us our cash for
acquisition.com to start Family Office.
And so, everything builds on itself. And
so, if you if you're going to have these
steps, it's like the steps are are are
set. It's just how soon do you want to
get to this step? It's just how late you
want to start, right? So,
next one is that I'll just rapid-fire
some reasons why I think it's better to
get rich while you're wrong young, which
is that like you also have more energy.
Right? So, think about it like this.
Like you you like you have to play the
cards you're dealt.
Getting those repetitions in takes
energy, and I only know this now that
I'm almost, you know, 40, which is wild
to say. Um that I have less energy than
I see some 18-year-olds, right? And so,
like that is a clear advantage that they
have. And so, if you have that, then
like you want to use it, right? In
addition to that, you have fewer
requirements, meaning there are are
fewer things that you must do. You
probably don't have kids yet. You
probably aren't, you know, wifed up yet
or or husbanded up yet. Um you probably
don't have the same level of geographic
dependence. And so, you are more
flexible. You can go to places where
learning can occur faster. You can have
fewer strings attached. You can live for
less, which means you can be more
aggressive with the excess cash that you
make to reinvest in skills or in formal
investments because you understand the
value of multiplying and compounding,
right? And again, this geographical
flexibility I think is wildly
underrated. One of the things that you
get the advantage of when you're younger
is that like if you want to be in, you
know, politics, go to DC. If you want to
be in finance, go to New York. If you
want to be in
uh if you want to be an in in influencer
in media, go to you know, go to LA,
right? Those are great places to learn.
Now, once you become Joe Rogan, you can
move to Austin and do whatever the hell
you want, right? But the thing is is
that when you want to get those reps,
you want to go where the reps are, are,
right? You want to go to where the fish
are if you're trying to fish. And what
you're fishing for right now is skills
and network, right? You're trying to get
places and you want to do it before you
have strings tying you down and roots
that you have set. And that is again,
it's a competitive advantage. It's not
to say that when you're older you can't
do it. It's just harder, right? And so,
if you believe that uh it's hard for you
now to uh forego your existing path,
which may have been given to you by your
siblings or society or whatever, I
promise you it will only get harder. And
if you can't do it now, the likely that
you're able to do it later goes down,
right? And for me, I want to stack bets
where the probabilities are highest for
my success. And whenever you enter a new
system, by the way, this is game theory,
the most adaptable player wins. So, it's
not It's like uh survival of the
fittest, right? And fittest is most
adaptable. And when you were younger,
you have the most adaptability. You have
the most neural plasticity as in you can
learn faster. You have the most energy
so you can do repetitions. You have the
least geographical uh constraints so you
can move to where the where the action
is. When you do earn, you make more
dollars on each dollar you make. All the
skills you acquire compound with time
cuz you only get better at it. The
accomplishments that you get from being
young mean more because you are young
than they do when they're old. And so,
the final point that I'll say is this,
is that you want to model success, not
the exceptions. Of course, we want to
tell the story of of uh of of Colonel
Sanders who started, you know, Colonel
Sanders when he was 63. And there's a
bunch of, you know, other uh kind of
call it exception stories of people who
are older
and then started companies
uh and then obviously were really
successful. But, like, wouldn't it be
better to be the rule than the
exception? Like, the richest people
often got rich when they were young
because they decided to, right? And I
will say this cuz I love this quote from
James Clear, but the thing that
separates winners and losers are not
their goals. People's goals are the
same. The difference between the people
who win and lose is the actions they
take as a result, and the risk that
they're willing to tolerate, and the
pain that they're willing to endure for
extended periods of time with an
uncertain payoff. And so, if you think
that you need certainty in order to move
forward, I promise you that this world
will never give it to you. And so, it's
really that there will always be
uncertain, and at some point you grow
the cojones, the gonads, by the way,
that's bisexual or unisex. Um
everybody's got uh gonads. Uh you will
grow the gonads, or they will drop, or
whatever it is.
Um I told you I was going to do some HR
stuff. Um you will grow the grow the
nads you need uh to take the bets. And
so, I think what really happens is that
at some point you realize that you're
not going to die if you fail, you will
just learn, and you will get better,
which is the point of the process. And
you will never finish, and you will
never actually win, because by the time
you win, you will have already planted a
much bigger goal that you want, because
the the goal that you had
came in shooting distance. And the
easiest analogy I can say for this is
this. When I wanted to,
you know, uh you know, bench 315, for
example, uh I was a dream of mine when I
was in high school, right? Cuz I
remember that just one big plate was a
was wow, the the strong kids could do a
full plate, right? And then two plates
was like super strong. Three plates was
crazy. By the time I bench 315, I knew I
was going to hit 315, because I had done
275 for five, and I did did 295 for, you
know, a triple or a set of five. And so,
315 seemed obvious, right? And so, the
thing is is that by the time you
accomplish goals, the goals themselves
seem less meaningful, because you
already did the work to make that goal
reasonable, which is why you achieved
it, which is why you have to do so much
work that is unreasonable that you do
not become successful, and the best way
to do that is to start when you're
younger for all the reasons I just gave.
All right. That's why you should succeed
while you're young. That's why you
should ignore the people who are telling
you uh who don't have what you want uh
telling you how to get something that
they've never gotten. If you like this
video and you're business owner who
wants to break through your current
revenue ceiling, I just spilled every
lesson from scaling 10 businesses past
10 million, and three businesses past
100 million into a completely free
scaling road map that I've used to go
from zero to one, zero to 10, and zero
to 100 plus. And so, you can click here
and you can check it out. Again,
absolutely free. And since you're a
business owner, appreciate you, and
enjoy.